(audience clapping)
- It's like you're a
magical present, walking in.
- Just wanted to match the set.
- Oh my God, with your hair in the braid,
you're so cute, right now.
(Zoey laughs)
I love the movie.
- Oh my God, I love you.
- Okay, I-
(audience cheering)
We're gonna get to it,
because I felt like rom-coms
died for a minute there,
and you're bringing it back!
- Gotta bring it back.
- I was very excited.
(audience cheering)
- Gotta bring it back.
- I love this, though. But I heard that-
are you a superstitious person?
I heard this about you.
- You know, I think,
well, it started early
and I actually, it has to
do with you, funny, you ask.
- Oh.
(Zoey chuckles)
- I claimed I was responsible
for you winning American Idol.
- Oh, did you call?
(audience cheering)
You called in? Oh my god, you voted?
- Yes, many, many times, of course.
- Oh, that's awesome.
- No, I was wearing a-
I don't, it was like a random pink ring
and I was sure that it had
something to do with you winning.
I don't know how or why
I attributed it to it.
- You just kept wearing it every time, oh.
- Every time, and I was like,
it's gotta be this ring.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
And then the next year,
when Ruben Studdard won,
I was like, I'm wearing the ring.
Like, I'm so powerful.
(audience laughs)
- Did it continue?
- No.
- Oh, oh.
It was just lucky for me and Ruben.
- Yeah. I think it was just you and Ruben.
Not the ring, but yeah.
That ring is no longer.
But there, you know, I have like random
other superstitions that I've developed.
Do you have any?
- Yes.
- [Zoey] Really?
- Yes,
I'm not like super, I'm
not, it's just like weird.
I think mine's more OCD.
- I have it, too.
- Yeah I think that's more-
- Do have like, does
your brain go to like,
if I don't do this, a
disaster's gonna happen?
- Yes.
- [Zoey] Oh yeah.
- Yes. Like crazy.
- Me too.
Like, I'll be like, if
I go down a water slide,
I'm like, oh I don't wanna
go down a second time,
but I have to because if I
don't do it a second time,
the world is gonna explode
- Because I believe in even numbers.
- Me too!
(Kelly vocalizes)
- I don't like odd numbers.
- Hate.
- So, yeah.
So, I don't do anything just once.
- Yeah, like shopping.
I have to touch fabrics
even number of times.
So then people will be like,
what's she doing in the corner?
And I'm like, 8, 16.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- People are like, she's weird.
- Is she okay?
I'm like, I'm great over here.
- That's hilarious too,
because your character
in the movie talks to what you're doing.
- Yes.
- Like, you talk to yourself
while you're doing- it's amazing.
- Yeah, I do.
- But wait, speaking of
rings, you were talking
about your pink ring,
but you posted something
about a ring that your
boyfriend has like, and you,
it's become an issue
for your relationship.
- Yeah, the Oura Ring.
Have you heard of that?
- Oh, someone was on
here. And it does, like
it keeps track of all
these things or something?
- Yeah. I mean-
- I want one.
- You need one?
- Okay.
(Zoey and audience laughs)
I like things like that.
- Yeah.
- For like three months and
then I never wear it again.
- Yes.
(audience and Kelly laughing)
- I hated it, I hated
it with a fiery passion
because he would wake up and be like,
oh I have, I slept great,
I'm gonna have a great day.
And then he'd look at his
score, his Oura Ring score,
and it would be like
it would be a low score
and all of a sudden he'd
be in a terrible mood
and the rest of the day was ruined.
And I was like, what is this thing?
So, I put it on blast on Instagram,
and Oura Ring was like,
let me send you one.
And I was like, okay, sure,
like I'm not gonna fall for it.
Cut to, it has now completely
taken over my life,
controlled everything.
I've changed my diet,
my sleep schedule, my lifestyle.
- Is it helpful though?
- It's so helpful.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, it'll tells you all
sorts of things about yourself.
- I kind of wanna put
like diamonds on blast
and see if anybody else send them to me.
(Zoey and audience laughing)
I'm like, I wanna start
putting things on blast.
Like yeah, I don't believe you, product.
And then have them send it to me.
That seems like an amazing thing to do.
I have heard of these though.
Somebody, I think, I feel
like a few people that
have come sat with me
and talked to me have had them
and they're obsessed with them.
- It also, you know, it's interesting.
It'll like tell you
what causes you anxiety
or who causes you anxiety
'cause your heart rate,
it detects your heart rate.
- Getting one tonight.
(Zoey laughs)
Yeah. I need to know this.
- It's fascinating.
I'll be like, I thought
I liked that person
but my Oura Ring says I
don't, so, you're out.
- Get out of here.
(Zoey and audience laughing)
So wait, you, you have Jewish
and Christian backgrounds
in your family?
- Yes.
So, they get to celebrate both.
Do you get to celebrate both?
- Best of both worlds, baby.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- Yeah, all the presents all the time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- All the food, yep.
- And it's think it's kind of cool
just to experience different
cultures in that time.
- That's that too, but the presents more.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- Yes. That's lovely.
- Right, the culture.
- Totally. Do you do anything like have
any like special things for either one?
- Well, you know my-
I don't know about what
traditions your family has,
but everything revolves
around food for us.
It's just all food centric.
- It seems like a good tradition, yeah.
- It's just all about the cooking
and it's all about the food.
My mom is the most, she
makes the best latkes,
even though she's not Jewish.
(Zoey laughs)
And her secret is, she puts a little bit
of Lawry's garlic salt in there.
- You're talking to a
Texan. I grew up on that
- [Zoey] Let me tell you.
- Yeah.
- It is, I feel like I am
25% Lawry's garlic salt.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
My grandma used to carry
around, in her purse,
Lawry's garlic salt, in little
thing, everywhere she went.
- So good.
- We got stopped
at the airport one time
because they thought
that she had drugs in her bag.
(audience laughs)
And I was like, I guess
it's kind of like a drug,
Lawry's garlic salt.
Not the kind that they're
looking for at TSA, but yeah.
So, runs in the family,
the love of garlic salt.
- That's a really good seasoning, though.
I'm with your grandma on this one.
So wait, speaking of traveling,
so you had some car issues.
Was it in Monaco?
- Oh, in Monaco, yeah.
- What happened?
(Zoey laughs)
And first of all, bravo,
just like driving in a different country.
- Oh, I was not.
- Oh, I was like, I don't do that.
- I'm pretty much the
worst driver in the world.
- Oh.
- In America, in anywhere.
- So wait, what happened then?
- Like, I live very close here
and I was like, I'd rather
walk here than drive.
- Do you have a bike?
- I'm a menace to society.
Way too ADHD.
I, yeah, we were in Monaco
and we were leaving an event
very early in the morning.
We're like, four, and we, I don't know how
somehow ended up on the track
for the Grand Prix in Monaco,
and they were all like coming on
and bringing all the cars
on for the Grand Prix.
So, we got stopped and
got pulled over by the-
there we are, see.
(audience laughing)
You can sort of see
like a glazed over drunk
look on my eyes, essentially.
- How does one accidentally
get on the Grand Prix?
Like that's-
- I think the driver
thought it was exciting to be honest.
(audience laughs)
Or we had something to do with it.
- Or you had a really
good inebriated idea.
- Yeah, I was like-
- Let's go!
- Let's go on the track.
- We're racecar drivers,
- Yeah, exactly.
- That's hilarious.
And four in the morning?
Oh my god, I'm too old.
(Zoey and audience laugh)
That just sounds exhausting, okay.
So, I wanna ask about this video.
This is you traveling in
Utah, you like to travel.
I love this.
- I do love to travel.
- So wait, what's happening here?
(Zoey screaming)
(audience laughing)
At least-
(Zoey screaming louder)
(audience laughs)
Yeah, you look like
you're having a good time.
- I'm warming up my vocal chords.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
As, really good for the, yeah.
- Do you, are you like
an adrenaline junkie?
- I'm so the opposite
of an adrenaline junkie.
But I, you know, my mom was really-
I'm very grateful to my mother
for so many different reasons,
but she was always like,
do hard things, do scary
things, push yourself.
I don't know if that's what she meant.
Like go on a bridge 700,
500, 600 feet in the air.
But, you know, I don't like
doing things like that.
But I push myself to and
I'm always glad that I-
- Wow.
- I do, you know?
- So, that was an experience for sure.
I didn't a 100% know what
I was getting myself into
when I said I would go rock climbing.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
That's hard.
- I know.
Have you ever done anything like that?
- Hell no, I don't do that, no, no.
(Zoey and audience laughing)
People are like,
I did, like, indoor one time,
and I was like, I'm out.
I got like three of-
I just, I was like super
athletic early 20s and like,
then like previous, and then
like after I just was tired.
(Zoey and audience laughing)
I just got tired.
I was like, no.
- I'm like, I want-
- But I'll hold you down.
I'll be the anchor at the bottom.
- I want someone to trick me
into going skydiving like ASAP
because if I don't do it
now, you know what I mean?
I gotta get that out of the way.
- My sister and my friend
did it, for their birthdays,
and I was like, you know what, no.
(Zoey laughs)
I was gonna do it.
And I was like, I worked
really hard for this life.
I'm not dying like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, no,
it's a bad way to go out.
- Now, if it's going down and
it's the only option, sure.
- [Zoey] Right.
- I'll jump right out, yeah.
- Somebody I know that did
it said like, you're gonna,
you have to do it because all you wanna do
is get out of that plane 'cause
it's so small and rickety.
They're like, I'm so happy
to jump out and fly on
into the sky 'cause it's,
that part is so much scarier.
- Yeah. My sister loved it.
So did my friend, but I was
like that's so good for you.
(audience laughs)
That's so nice.
- Yeah, like the videos of people
when they land and
they're like, I'm alive!
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
I'll just walk around
right now and say it,
like I need to do something
risky to be happy about it.
It's like, so wait, I wanna
ask about your new movie
because I loved it and
I know I led with like,
I really, I wrote this in
your card too backstage,
I've always complain
that rom-coms have died.
- Yeah.
- Like I grew up
in a generation, 'cause I'm a lot older,
I'm like-
- No.
- 15 years older than me, whatever.
But I grew up in a generation where we
had just so many amazing rom-coms.
- [Zoey] Yeah.
- And I love it.
And so I feel like there haven't been any
and not only are you in it,
but you're producing, right?
- Yes.
- That's incredible.
(audience cheers)
- Thanks.
- [Kelly] And it's so good.
- Thank you.
- Like I watched it and I was
so nervous cause I was like,
they're just not as good anymore,
and it was so good.
- Well-
- And chemistry is so good.
- Yeah and I got to make
it with Reese Witherspoon,
who's like the queen.
- [Kelly] Oh, I didn't know that!
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Oh I didn't know that.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- So, she, about four years ago,
saw a movie that I did called, Set It Up,
which was another rom-com.
- I love Set It Up.
(audience cheers)
I love Set It Up, that was another one.
I was like shocked, I was
like, it's not gonna be good.
And I was like, damn.
- I'm only gonna make
good ones. I've made two.
- I know!
- And now,
I only wanna make good ones.
- Those are so good.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- So she saw it
and she was like, I love this.
Why aren't there more great
feel good romantic movies?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And then,
we started talking and we worked on this
for a while and now
it's finally coming out
and I'm so proud of it and I'm
so proud of making something
that makes people feel good, you know?
- And it's a fresh story.
- [Zoey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
Like wait, tell everybody-
that nobody's seen me yet,
I only have that.
- Yes.
No, but you will on December 9.
(audience cheers)
Something From Tiffany's is about a girl,
whose life is forever changed by receiving
an engagement ring that was
meant for somebody else.
And it's about how
love, like life, is full
of unexpected surprises and gifts
and it's a beautiful feel
good romantic holiday movie
that you are going to
watch over and over again.
I can tell.
(audience cheers)
- Yes, so good.
I kept hoping for the ending.
And I was like, please say
this is gonna turn around.
And then I was like, at
the very end, I was like,
I love this movie.
I was like, it made me feel so good.
I'd been sick for like
three weeks, I swear to God.
And I was like watching
it going, I'm so happy.
(Zoey laughs)
I was like-